m night shyamalan is back with a brand
new horror film
from its star-studded cast to its
strange premise and sooner than expected
release date here's everything we know
about
old so far movies don't appear out of
thin air of course and m night shyamalan
actually began laying the official
groundwork for old as
early as 2019 and may have read the
source material that inspired the film
way back in 2017.
in september 2019 it was announced that
shyamalan had partnered up with studio
universal pictures for two more feature
films
the films both described as thrillers
were at the time slated for release on
february 26th
2021 and february 17 2023 but
no additional information was shared
publicly at the time
m night shyamalan has amassed a talented
bunch of actors for the film
phantom thread actress vicky creeps and
mozart in the jungle actor gael garcia
bernal play prisca and guy
the couple who first noticed the beach's
bizarre effects when their young son
trent
quickly turns into a fully grown man
trent is played by alex wolfe who you
may know from hereditary
jojo rabbit star thomas and mackenzie
will also appear as the older version of
maddox priskin guy's daughter
and trans sister additionally embeth
davids probably best known to the masses
as miss honey from matilda and
men in the high castles rufus sewell
play a married couple who are among the
group
affected by the creepy side effects of
this holiday destination
the devil all the time star eliza
scanlon is also part of the old cast
playing yet another child rapidly aged
up for the upcoming film
lost alum ken leung returns to the big
screen for the first time since 2015
star wars the force awakens
with a cast in place and a green light
for production flashing
the old team could begin filming yes
even amid the kovid 19 pandemic
luckily for old the situation regarding
the novel coronavirus had somewhat
settled down from its initial worldwide
surge in the early months of 2020 by the
time
principal photography was looking to
begin in september of that year
many movie and television show
productions that were forced to spend
filming indefinitely beginning in march
and april 2020
got the cameras rolling once again in
the early autumn months so it was prime
time
for old to start shooting as well
shyamalan took to twitter on september
26
2020 to announce that filming had begun
that day was also the first time
anyone in the public learned that film
was titled old
he wrote in the caption feels like a
miracle that i'm standing here
shooting the first shot of my new film
it's called old
getting started on filming old may have
felt miraculous but it wasn't always
blue skies and sunshine
and we mean that literally old was shot
in the dominican republic which is quite
a far leap from shyamalan's hometown of
philadelphia pennsylvania where he shot
most of his previous movies
speaking during a panel at the 2021
tribeca film festival
m night shyamalan got candid about some
of the obstacles he ran into while
filming old even in such a beautiful
location
we were the first movie to shoot and
cast in the pandemic and the way we were
making a movie
was very new i was making up the rules
because i was the first one
we didn't have a single positive case
which is fantastic
even if it's very scary but because of
this we had to push from may into
hurricane season
shyamalan continued there was a
hurricane before filming began
and it took the sets and just destroyed
them we decided to build again but the
biggest concern was that the beach had
eroded there was no beach for our beach
movie
thankfully part of the beach came back
on the first day of shooting but because
of the complex nature of the film's
story another issue is keeping a tight
schedule
juggling tons of different actors on the
set each day and
regularly sending actors to and from
hair and makeup
the actors are aging and it's one day in
the movies so if an actor was playing
alex wolf's character young they would
be in the morning then another would be
in the daytime and then there'd be
another actor later there was all these
prosthetics and it was a very
complicated thing
actor alex wolf who moderated the
tribeca film festival panel said it felt
like kismet to be filming a movie about
time stopping during an
era of history where a pandemic has made
time feel
unreal hurricanes complicated schedules
and prosthetics be
darned old wrapped production on
november 15th 2020
less than two months after filming
started shyamalan tweeted
wrapped production on old the movie it
was an incredible experience
beyond grateful to the people of the
dominican republic who are so caring and
welcoming
it is one of the most beautiful
countries filled with the sweetest
people
thinking of you as i head back to philly
before filming even began though
universal pictures announced that old
then one of shyamalan's two untitled
thrillers wouldn't debut on february 23
2021 as intended instead it would launch
on july 23rd
the super bowl teaser for old confirms
the july 23rd release date and the film
is currently on schedule to arrive in
theaters on that day
as for when old will be available to
stream from home there's been no word
just yet but
it definitely seems like the type of
movie that would perform well as a
rental
on the same day that m night shyamalan
announced the start of filming collider
ran an exclusive report to revealing
both the basic premise of old and the
graphic novel that inspired it
sandcastle written by pierre scott levy
and illustrated by frederick peters
in a tweet posted on june 24 2017
shyamalan shared a photo of six graphic
novels and comics spread out on a table
he captioned it quote next up to read to
inspire
glass writing one of the written works
seen in the photo was sandcastle
according to an insider close to
collider someone gifted shyamalan
sandcastle for father's day and
after reading it he reached out to the
appropriate people and bought the
screenwrites to the work
while sand castle may have had some sort
of impact on shyamalan's 2019 featured
glass
it actually ended up spurring the
filmmaker to create an entirely new
movie
old sees a family trapped on a secluded
beach as everyone begins to age at a
terrifying rate
the group quickly start to lose their
sanity as they no longer recognize their
own selves
and the film even uses a dash of body
horror for good measure
as a surprise pregnancy catches a young
woman off guard in a truly disturbing
fashion
the footage of old shown at the 2021
super bowl shows members of the group
searching for answers across the beach
with shots of alex wolfe and thomas and
mckenzie's characters investigating
something in a cave with shyamalan's
infamous love of shocking third act
revelations
it'll be interesting to see why the
horrifying phenomenon is happening to
this specific group of people
one line of dialogue even suggests that
it's being done to them by someone or
something
we're here for a reason meanwhile sand
castle centers around 13 people trapped
on a beach
who begin unraveling a sister secret
about time old isn't fully based off
sand castle just inspired by it and the
graphic novel doesn't offer much
explanation behind the horrifying events
instead it's more of an analysis of the
human condition back in 2013
peters told comic book resources that a
shocking twist was originally part of
the ending but
was scrapped because it quote would have
destroyed the frightening dimension of
the book
perhaps viewers will see levi's original
ending on the big screen
well maybe not according to m night
shyamalan himself he's still working on
the ending of old as of late june 2021
at the 2021 tribeca film festival the
filmmaker described old as being
subversive and
even inappropriate then drop to the
bombshell that he's tinkering with the
film's ending to ensure the story is
left on just the right note
i'm deciding on the minor note how to
end on a minor note
another one of shyamalan's movies that
ends in such a way is unbreakable the
2000 superhero thriller starring bruce
willis as the titular
unbreakable man david dunn and samuel
jackson as the secretly nefarious elijah
price who's revealed to be the big bad
shyamalan is hoping to replicate the
feeling of that reveal from unbreakable
in the ending of old hence why he's
still adjusting it a month out from
release
shyamalan added that unbreakable ends on
a kind of a dip
right he goes to the dark note that
minor note at the end
the guy you thought was the best friend
is the villain
the minor note sticks to you forever
as is par for the course with any m
night shyamalan film many different
theories about old have surfaced online
as curious movie fans try to predict
what the whole thing is really about
one theory is that the parents who are
stuck on the beach are suffering from
dementia and it's affecting their
perception of time and reality
reddit user the dumbest timeline was one
of many who posited this idea and it
actually holds some weight
shyamalan's own father has dementia the
filmmaker said during the 2021 tribeca
film festival
my father's very old right now he has
dementia he comes and goes
shyamalan has implemented dementia as a
storytelling device in 2015's the visit
however
so as plausible as this theory seems one
might be able to rule it out on the
possible basis of shyamalan wanting to
avoid repetition
another old theory is that we're dealing
with good old-fashioned time loop
one twitter user noted that both she and
her husband subscribe to this theory
it's a basic one but it makes a lot of
sense on the other side perhaps there's
some sort of dangerous entity
controlling time on the island more
specifically
the beach and the water and is punishing
the humans for whatever reason
one redditor thinks that quote the twist
will be that time was moving faster yet
their brains were not
another user on reddit believes that
something along these lines will play
out
the ocean was stuck in time but there
were pockets in space-time that were
kinda still keeping up through
regular time so they aged faster when
they just
actually caught up with time or maybe
none of that will ring true and
shyamalan will subvert
expectations by not including a third
act twist like he usually does
only time will tell it's a mystery
wrapped in a riddle inside an enigma
whatever ends up happening in old twist
ending or no twist ending one thing is
for certain
the movie will be unlike anything you've
seen before from m night shyamalan or
any other film director
at least that's what shyamalan has
promised is the case he said at the
tribeca film festival
no one has ever seen anything like it in
its tone and the way it's just i mean
it's like nothing else of course there's
a big chance that shyamalan has an
inflated opinion of old since it's a
movie he wrote directed and produced but
there's little denying that hype for the
film is real many online have expressed
their excitement to see old once it
arrives in theaters on july 23rd and
countless fans have stated that even if
old doesn't live up to all their
expectations
they're just eager to find out what's
truly going on in the story
how it all comes together and what it
all means check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one